[Music]
our series a more perfect union aims to
show that what unites us as americans
is far greater than what divides us this
morning
we're introducing you to a 12 year old
girl who composed a piece of music
for some of the world's most talented
classical musicians
nancy chen shows us how she wanted to
inspire more diversity among composers
by hitting the road with the new york's
philharmonics bandwagon
concert series in the shadow of the
brooklyn bridge
musicians from the new york philharmonic
are performing a
world premiere
[Music]
it's an important first for the piece's
composer
12 year old grace moore
while the young composer is still
getting used to the spotlight
she and her mother clara met me at the
world renowned lincoln center
for decades musicians have been coming
here to take
center stage
what goes into composing a piece of
music
where do you even start well you start
by
creating i guess a catchy bunch of notes
then you just add on to those notes okay
sorry one second
after you repeat can you play it a
little faster the brooklyn 7th grader is
part of the philharmonic's very young
composers
a program that teaches children how to
create
music philharmonic president deborah
borta says
it's all part of a mission to expose
classical music
to new audiences and creators it is
critical that symphony orchestras
which frankly have been seen as a sort
of
elite bastion a very white bastion
that we begin to live in the 21st
century that
we invite in
people of color of all different kinds
and we have the composer here with us
grace moore
she was very excited about the fact that
she could represent
as a black female composer and also such
a young person
well i guess i could attract more of a
different kind of viewer
i haven't really seen many people who
look like me on stage
partnering with metropolitan opera star
anthony roth costanzo
philharmonic musicians perform pop-up
concerts
out of a rented pickup truck
sometimes there'll be a fire our garbage
truck is blocking where we were going to
play
it's new york it's new york world-class
players used to performing in
architecturally stunning and 10-drop
quiet symphony halls
are instead playing to the soundtrack of
the streets of new york
sharing music in neighborhoods all over
the city in rain
or shine
[Music]
[Applause]
the surprise concerts have hit a high
note with audiences
everyone listening to live music kind of
felt like the community coming together
and for the admittedly shy composer
sharing her music has allowed her to
feel
heard in more ways than one music is
universal
it doesn't matter where you are or where
you're from or what language you speak
everyone can understand it for cbs this
morning nancy chen
new york
it's so great when you come around a
corner in new york city and all of a
sudden you see
something like that and you know what i
like though i like seeing people like
grace moore
yes who's 12 years old who's a little
girl of color
who i i like what deborah borda said
that it's normally a white elite bastion
right and so it's 20 20 opening up the
doors and just the message that it sends
and look i love the confidence of grace
too could you do that a little faster
right after she knows what she's
ever what she wants everything about
this is bringing music to the people
more than
you know what we've seen in the past
she's also right about this anthony you
know i say this all the time music is
universal doesn't matter what language
you are what color you are
it it resonates and i do like that line
starting with a catchy bunch of notes
she's right